les chéris on est devant on est devant
le studio regardez on abuse historique
[Applaudissements]
avec tout ce qu'ils veulent faire et ce
soir on ne pouvait pas passer les huit
ans
[Applaudissements]
pour cela soirée mousse ou les cherry on
est en août
regardez c'est beau on est en route pour
sa face avant les quotas
[Musique]
mais faire c'est pékin express à
l'arrivée ça on va faire ce qu'on leur
dit ouah genou a atteint maintenant wali
laquelle rasta l on peut plus garder ça
alors là c'est la foule faire la préfère
la paire vers la paix faire la paix bien
entendu regardez c'est beau c'est en
trois lettres c'est un thé c'est un f
et c'est un d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
trois lettres c'est de l'été un chip te
dit tu ne capte une péninsule
nous y sommes et 10 mois sur la tête de
ma mère j'ai la passion que pour faire
dit m on met une heure sur la vie de ma
mère
servi dans l'art le cas on voit sur la
vidéo silence qu'attend le gars effet
commencé à essayer pour avancer mon plat
alors les séries les chéris
[Applaudissements]
ça y est
j'irai revenus et ollier allez on va les
défendre parce que les chéris ça va être
le fire
cette folie
[Musique]
à
quelque chose
la musique est ce qu'on peut enlever la
musique les chéris j'aimerais vous dire
quelque chose
le grand patron tef à ceara on voudrait
se réconcilier avec lui et lui dire
qu'on les aime parce que lui tend c'est
grâce à lui aussi que tpm paix à 8 ans
donc merci à lui qui a lancé l émission
sur direct 8
merci ara aprikian merci mon chéri tu
sais qu'on t'aime
voilà et que c'est grâce à toi aussi
qu'on est là donc les chéris awards se
réconcilier avec eux on va arriver et
dans un instant on aura une surprise
pour eux puisqu'on aura le totem de la
réconciliation je vous demander de bien
vouloir venir avec moi
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
il
comment ça va mais chérie ça valait
chérie ça va les chéris bercy développe
sa main des séries
la pala
attendez attendez attendez l'échelle
atomique
attendez les chéris attendez attendez
attendez l'échelle est ce que vous êtes
content d'être là
[Applaudissements]
les os 4 petites secondes
je voudrais qu'on amène je voulais qu'on
amène oui monsieur qu'est ce que fait la
main et chérie je voudrais qu'on a mais
ça c'est la faute aux oscars deux
minutes le shérif apprenez à connaître
les chéris d'echery juste jouer mon ya
un truc dans le lait les chéris jeudi en
hommage en hommage regardez regardez ce
qui arrive c'est le totem de 8 m pour la
réconciliation
merci nos amis
[Applaudissements]
c'est aussi avec des vents va accrocher
cette statue la tête froide et solide
voilà
sidaction
avec havas
merci mon chéri cy young
[Applaudissements]
prakash pas m
mecheri c'est vrai qu'aussi bien sûr
n'était pas servir les selles
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tout chaud
à puteaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous ses biens
j'ai regardé
cette folie
gamesa
ça
[Applaudissements]
mais j'espère que tout ça va devrait
continuer à quelles fins je vais vous
dire que je vous aime très très fort
j'espère que vous avez passé une bonne
sera avec nous et n'oubliez pas la télé
c'est que tu as
[Applaudissements]